moi aussi d'avoir pendant que tu es là
de le voir avec tous derrière toi le
porte à gauche la toit plat rivières les
rivières en fils carrière celle aussi
d'un chagrin il faut virer voilà on va
le prendre est de loin tout pour être le
plus loin est ce que passé le vieux l'ag
après voilà je vais des piquets en
remportant
depuis 2001 c'est une maison un
traitement qu'on va faire on va faire un
plan assez bas un cas rien changé police
a saisi couteyen si tous n'ont pas
trouvé preneur je vous je vois des cas
la paix par la droite
enfin possible vers le village et le et
la rivière on alors c'est pas comme ça
qu'il faut faire c'est points d'arrêt
bien dans l'autre sens toi qui tu vois
la voie vers le bout le pouls du village
toi c'est très joli damas voilà voilà
vas tu vois ça regarde la rivière que
like this voilà tu joues un peu
d'anciens nazis ok on va les tuer
maintenant on va les tuer on va
descendre un peu dessus voilà quoi tu
peux à le descendre et puis
le push de l'enterrement après six ans
un passage à ses bottes du village ou
pas saison et égyptiens attentes assure
le dg en large et vous voilà voilà
tu vois la tour nerveux dans la droite
pour rejoindre le verre tu vois la
droite ont quitté pas vu les jeux pour
les enfants ont besoin comme ça lors du
super bowl un autre jour et lumière le
plaquent les équipes qui pouvaient eux c
est l esprit qu étant largement peu à
différents plans de licenciements veut
hockey
on va faire un petit passage en bas on
voulait un peu passage à peu vers le bas
des villages non oui le godard jeu
hockey balle à terre tandis qu'arsène et
le monde et du coup tu as encore
c'est pas passionnant parce qu'on attend
qu'il élabore ce qu'on soit on l'enverra
l'un c'est beaucoup plus beau à offrir à
la tension règne lui ai rien d'abord
c'est pas désert devant des artifices
derrière les enfants ici un peu plus
haut sur l'eau sur le visage un peu ils
n'en font serré voilà sa route
bah quoi or le peu de villes et villages
en villages de 17 heures ils ont fermé
le parc hé bien c'est bien simple on
rentre je veux a et 1 quand même mieux
que ça va si bien
alors tranquillement ce groupe de vente
est très beau pote fait politique
avery et chicago la caf précise 0 ok on
va tourner régis quelqu'un on va tourner
comme ça week after this du cap bon
alsace et redon les à brown nathan cela
vous coûte jusque de turin parce que je
voulais couper le jeu couper le pain est
plutôt qu'en fait-on rouge qui est
dégueulasse qui arrive là d'accord c'est
pour toi le port de moss mambo je suis
leur dira village de touristes et c'en
est un c'est pour ça que je sais qu'il
avait servi aux deux parties et 17h
voilà qu'ils aient touristiques réalisés
à personne sauf à l'épaule cncd chèvre
la gauche a vu à samia g châssis raconte
reçu frais
vous essayez de faire un stationnaire au
dessus des chèvres non non non non non
non c'est évident ici c'est après ce
pendentif villages souvent vasculaire sa
part et les gens y ont déjà essayé des
gens du village là tu veux te voir des
gens ou pas on voit des gens et
beaucoup trop